du livre cry notre correspondant
gulliver bonjour on l'a vu dans la
région de karkhiv la contre-offensive de
l'armée ukrainienne mme semble porter
ses fruits
oui quatre villages supplémentaires
selon le président ukrainien ont été
reconquis par les forces us craignant
ces dernières 24 heures ce qui s'ajoute
à des territoires qu'ils avaient déjà à
gagner ces derniers jours
donc ils repoussent les forces russes
plus loin de la ville d'ark yves leur
artillerie selon les militaires
l'ukrainien n'est plus en mesure de
frapper la ville d'ark yves même cela ne
veut pas dire karkhiv ne peut pas être
frappé par des roquettes qui sont tirés
à de plus longues distances ou bien par
des frappes aériennes
mais en tout cas ça augmente la sécurité
de la ville d'art clip qui est la
deuxième ville de l'ukraine et puis
aussi lit un élément stratégique qui est
que ces avancées vise aussi à couper les
lignes des forces russes de qui leur
fournissent leurs troupes qui sont plus
au sud dans la région de rare qu'yves
près de la ville d'izu mme qui est leur
sort de place d'armes d'où ils lancent
les offensives un put peu plus vers le
sud vers la région du donbass et là dans
le donbass les russes continuent à
avancer mais vraiment à petit pas ils
sont très loin d'atteindre leurs
objectifs sont la raison dont la région
pardon mais cela bien sûr n'est pas sans
infliger des pertes horrible notamment
au civil par exemple la ville de
severodonetsk que les autorités dans
cette ville maintenant on dit que 70%
des bâtiments de la ville qui est la
plus grande ville ukrainienne si vous
voulez que sous contrôle ukrainienne
dans la région de lougansk est bien 70 %
des bâtiments auraient subi quelques
endommagement et 30% serait en ce moment
in inhabitable et puis un gulliver au
sud est du pays dans la ville de
marioupol presque entièrement
aujourd'hui aux mains des russes plus
d'un les militaires d'ukrainiens dont
des centaines de blessés se trouve
toujours dans une usine asos talent
c'est ce qu'ont annoncé hier les
autorités ukrainiennes et puis des
images de ces soldats qui résistent
viennent d'être diffusés
oui les soldats diffuse des images de
soldats blessés pour essayer d'attirer
l'attention nationale et internationale
ils veulent obtenir une action eux
estiment qu'il serait possible de les
extraire par la voie militaire ou par
des négociations politiques ce qu'ils
réclament c'est l'extraction ils sont
prêts à être emmenés dans un pays tiers
où il resterait jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre ils ne sont pas prêts à se rendre
aux russes même pas ce qu'ils disent que
s'ils seront aux russes ils seront tués
mais ils sont prêts si vous voulez à
être prisonnier dans un pays tiers c'est
la procédure qui s'appelle extraction
c'est ce pourquoi ils militent en ce
moment et donc ces images servent à
souligner leur situation qui est
absolument désespéré vous voyez des gens
qui ont dû des bras ou des jambes
amputées
dans une conférence de presse donnée ce
week end le porte-parole des combattants
du régime en azote expliqué que ce sont
des opérations qui ont été menées avec
succès mais qui sont vraiment des
opérations qui peuvent sauver la vie de
quelqu'un à court terme mais cette
personne doit vraiment être amené dans
un un vrai hôpital pour poursuivre son
traitement sinon ces blessures vont
continuer enfin finir en finiront par
par constituer une menace pour la vie de
cette personne merci beaucoup d'univers
craag